he is an old buffoon who should be
rotting in a prison cell uh and if rand
paul has his uh way i'm pretty sure
that's what's gonna happen to anthony
fauci because uh here he was friday on
the very day that they announced that
fauci had coveted here's rand paul just
grilling the hell out of him on vaccine
misinformation
dr fauci the government recommends
everybody take a booster over age five
are you aware of any studies that show
reduction in hospitalization or death
for children who take a booster
right now there's not enough data that
has been accumulated senator paul
to indicate that that's the case there
are no studies on children showing a
reduction in hospitalization or death
with taking a booster if i give you 10
or if i give a patient 10 mrna vaccines
and they make protein each time or they
make antibody each time is that proof
that we should give 10 boosters dr fauci
no that i think that is somewhat of an
absurd exaggeration so that is the proof
that you use your committees use that
that's the only proof you have to tell
children to take a booster is that they
make antibodies so it's not an absurdity
you're already at like five boosters for
people you've had you know two or three
boosters it's like where is the proof
now i think there is probably some
indication for older folks that have
some risk factors for younger folks
there's not
rand paul is really fantastic you know
we can bash on politic politicians all
the time and you know there's a short
list of politicians i like but he really
is great and he's got the chops when
he's in those conversations right he
actually is a doctor what's incredible
about that now first off it came out
that fauci had coveted a little bit
after that but you can hear it in fauci
that he's obviously not feeling well but
we really need to think about this the
cdc is now recommending boosters
basically for five-year-olds there is no
evidence that it works and fauci's
admitting it and they're still pushing
it do you realize how insane that is two
and a half years after two weeks to
flatten the curve how completely insane
it is and rand paul continued to to bash
him on these lies and this
misinformation when it comes to vaccine
kids and if you look at the data from
israel
the boosts both the third shot boost and
the fourth shot boost
was associated with a clear-cut clinical
effect mostly in elderly people
but also as they gathered more data even
in people in the 40s and the 50s so
there is clinical data but not in
children
well well see here's the thing is you're
not willing to be honest with the
american people so for example 75
percent of kids have had the disease
why is the cdc not including this in the
data you can ask the question you can do
laboratory tests to find out who's had
it and who hasn't had the disease
what is the incidence of hospitalization
and death for children who've been
infected with kovid
subsequently going to the hospital or
dying what what is the possibility if
your kid has had covid which is 75 of
the country's head covered what is the
chance that my child's going to the
hospital or dying
if you look at the number of deaths in
pediatrics senator you can see that
there are more deaths of people who have
had it
but people have had the disease
senator we also know from other studies
that the optimal degree of protection
when you get infection is to get
vaccinated after infection but you can't
answer the question i ask the question i
ask is how many kids are dying and how
many kids are going to the hospital who
have already had covid the answer may be
zero but you're not even giving us the
data because you have so much wanted to
protect everybody from all the data
because we're not smart enough to look
at the data when you release data
earlier when the cdc released the data
they left out the category of 18 to 49
on whether or not there was a health
benefit for for adults 18 to 49 why was
it left out
when critics finally complained it was
finally included because there was no
health benefit from taking a booster
between the 18 to 49 and the cdc study
you know it's interesting the government
has all sorts of hearings all the time
and it's usually just like pure nonsense
and theatrics and nothing comes of any
of it but i thought this was important
to show you because rand paul is
prosecuting him right there right he's
prosecuting him and eventually he'll be
persecuting him because
what he is saying what fauci is saying
is oh there is a study in another
country in this case in israel that
third and fourth booster shots for
adults does something and he gives you
this sort of amorphous it kind of does
something for 40 and 50 year olds and
and ran says well wait a minute so this
has nothing to do with kids you have no
numbers related to kids and because of
this study in another country from 40 to
on 40 to 50 year olds you now want to
inject our kids even further and
fouchy's got nothing he's got nothing he
is a criminal and a fraud that's what
anthony fauci is